annick des cinq bourgeois bonjour alors
vous avez plusieurs casquettes quant aux
enseignants que quand on dit rice quant
aux autres auteurs et alors vous lancez
opérations à venir 2021 est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus oui
opérations à mener en font c'est un
projet qu'on a lancé il ya trois ans qui
annuel
et puis qui venait vraiment justement de
mon passé d'enseignant parce que je
voyais qu'il y avait des besoins pour du
matériel ludique pédagogique qui
informerait les jeunes au secondaire sur
les domaines en émergence au niveau de
l'emploi mais plus au sens large donc
exploré différents domaines en émergence
différents domaines dans autant dans les
statistiques d'emploi que dans les
détails de compétences et puis de
technologie kth apprend dans le futur
pour occuper ces domaines et que les la
pertinence de cette opération
aujourd'hui on est en plein contexte de
pandémie de covin le 19 ont lu ton
combat dans tous les sens pour essayer
de s'en sortir et vous vous parler
d'avenir 2021 c'est quoi la pertinence
de ce projet là aujourd'hui mais je
pense qu'elle est jeune plus que jamais
ils sont dans l'indécision sont dans
l'incertitude les lions des choix
affable si le 1er mars pour leur choix
de formation dans l'avenir c'est
d'autant plus difficile quand on sait
pas ce que l'avenir nous réserve
trop trop on dit que 50 % des jeunes
savent pas quoi choisir comme domaines
d'emploi pour le futur donc ces tables
les informer dans ton on se dit que plus
je ne connais d'informations sur
différents domaines plus de chance de
trouver chaussure à son pied
donc il ya les gens qu'on a souvent les
domaines que leurs parents occupent ou
encore qu'ils ont vu à la télé oui
qu'ils ont vu dans des films avocats
enseignants infirmiers médecins mais
connaissent moins d'autres domaines qui
pourraient vraiment les intéressait
vraiment répondre à leurs compétences à
leur habileté qui au milieu de travail
aussi dans lequel ils veulent travailler
vous semblez avoir ciblé quelques
domaines prioritaires alors surgir eux
oui c'est ça on a dans le fond à chaque
année pour l'opération en avons fait le
tour des partenaires du marché du
travail
on leur demande s'ils ont des visions
pour le futur s'ils ont des choses à
partager aux jeunes
et cette année à 7 milieux qui ont
répondu à l'appel donc les ressources
humaines l'aérospatiale la comptabilité
l'assurance dommage la ferme et
biotechnologies la force de vie et les
technologies qui sont des domaines très
diversifiés qui présente un peu tout le
secteur pour chacun de leurs
possibilités dans leur domaine et plus
présente les emplois les compétences les
statistiques et aussi sur tout ce qu'on
voulait viser cette année s'est présenté
que le télétravail ce n'est pas
nécessairement la norme qu'il ya plein
de possibilités comme environnement
travaille dans différents domaines et
qu'on voulait démontrer que autant
quelqu'un en foresterie peut travailler
dans un bureau que dans la forêt autant
comptable peu sur une équipe sportive
sur la route
quelqu'un en aérospatiale peut
travailler dans un aéroport dans un dans
une usine peut travailler à différents
endroits
espérons pour démystifier ce côté là
aussi
et comment entendez vous apporter cette
information-là aux jeunes est ce que
c'est un document que vous lancez
lens-lille est ce qu'il y aura de ces
mineurs comme des espèces de six ans
d'enseignement en fait est un document
papier qui disponible pour tous les
enseignants intervenants partout dans la
province de québec donc qui est
distribué gratuitement des enseignants
les intervenants font la commande pour
leur groupe lance c'est vraiment un
petit fascicule papier qui faciles à
étudier pas s'il a donné aux jeunes
c'est à la fois des pages informatique
puis les pages de d'activités
pédagogiques fait que j'ai vraiment
pensé dans l'esprit de quand j'étais en
classe
qu'est ce que j'aurais aimé avoir comme
intervenants scolaires pour mes jeunes
puis qu'est ce que mes jeunes auraient
aimé comme un type d'activité sexy
vraiment des petites activités pour
qu'ils explorent les différents domaines
qui s'y intéressent qui aille plus loin
et aussi du matériel pour l'intervenant
pour utiliser ce petit cahier l'heure
dans le fond avec leurs jeunes autant en
classe à présent ciel quand virtuel
c'est que c'est très bien de ce côté là
plus qu'un plupart s'en fera pas doublon
avec ce que le conseiller en orientation
scolaire au fond de jeu mais en fait ces
deux des outils pour les conseillers
d'orientation
parce que ils ont toutes sortes de
houthis est certaine il y en existe déjà
mais étant donné que c'est du matériel
qui est fait pour cette année avec les
les domaines de cette année c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir du matériel
de plus pour nos jeunes et puis à du
matériel nouveau et c'est vraiment fait
avec les conseils d'orientation à
l'esprit et puis leur travail pour leur
faciliter aussi en ce moment il ya une
lourde charge énormément de jonas lui et
puis dans tout le contexte de la
pandémie
je suis certaine que le contexte encore
plus l'eau il l'était déjà
donc on veut les outiller avec cette
foutue l'on veut aussi outiller les
parents qui veulent télécharger tout
simplement le fascicule ils peuvent
aller en ligne sur opérations en mer
télécharger le bascule
c'est aussi un bon point de départ de
discussion sur la cne pour nos jeunes
souvent on sait pas trop comment
approcher le sujet on veux pas être
critique par rapport à leur choix on
veut leur ouvrir les horizons
on veut enlever certains mythes certains
tabous fait que je trouve que c'est un
beau point de départ d'une conversation
moi j'ai j'ai trois jeunes à la maison
de différents âges que je trouve que à
chaque année c'est une belle
conversation qu'on a sur l'avenir
comme on ne voit pas comment ce père
soit appliquée l'un pas qu'on verra dans
la société
quel genre rôle on veut jouer dans son
emploi futur dites moi avec des sels ça
fait quand même quelques années que le
document est lancé est ce que vous avez
comme l'impression qu'il ya de
l'engouement autour de ce document là
est ce que les jeunes sont intéressés
en termes de bilan que ce qu'on peut
dire par rapport à ce qui est possible
oui sans grand succès sinon ferait pas
chaque année parce que ça demande
énormément d'efforts et de travail
mais dès la première année on avait des
visées assez simple de faire 5000
exemplaires puis des lancers dans tout
le québec
mais les 5000 exemplaires se sont
écoulés en quelques semaines on en était
en réimpression deux fois pour suffire à
la demande l'année dernière on avait
imprimé 25000 exemplaires qui était très
bon en comptant est mis cette année on
vise encore 25000 exemplaires et nous on
a déjà 5800 copier en date d'hier qui se
sont envolés depuis lundi qu'ils ont été
commandés par les milieux sequi y avait
vraiment une attente du milieu d'avoir
ce fascicule de l'avoir en main et on a
un petit concours en ligne pour ceux qui
ont le fascicule pour les jeunes et puis
l'an dernier
on recevait les résultats il faut
fallait qu'ils remplissent un petit
sondage pour participer au concours
c'est l'fun parce que les jeunes nous
disait assez cool j'ai découvert tel
domaine c'est intéressant
les commentaires qui prenait la peine
d'écrire en plus pour un ado c'est pas
toujours facile d'écrire un commentaire
et on n'a pas eu aucun commentaire
négatif très surprenant
je suis entièrement transparente avec
vous ça m'a beaucoup surpris tous les
commentaires ont été postés fait qu' on
en or je pense qu'on a apprécié beaucoup
ça nous donne aussi de l'énergie pour
leur faire don en année puisque c'est un
long travail mais c'est un bel
aboutissement
on sait que ces essais c'est d'intérêt
pour les jeunes puis c'est un bon outil
aussi pour les conseillers d'orientation
que les intervenants dans les menus
scolaires qui doivent aider nos jeunes
dans leur choix
tafer dites moi une dernière question
d'où vous est venue l'idée de lancer un
tel document est ce que vous avez senti
comme un besoin de le faire
est ce que c'est vraiment nécessaire
mais dans le passé on avait nos
publications qui s'appelait le palmarès
des carrières étaient vendus c'était
vraiment un livre qui faisait vraiment
palmarès mais pardonnez moi statistiques
des emplois de l'avenir par rapport à
vraiment le nombre d'emplois dans le
domaine depuis quand on le regardait du
côté éthique on se disait bien choisir
un emploi par rapport à des statistiques
peuvent choisir non pas par rapport à
ses goûts ses compétences et habiletés
ce qu'on veut faire c'est passion et ça
allait pas vraiment dans notre ligne de
pensée qui fait qu'on a reviré de ce
projet là en se disant qu'ils qu'est-ce
que un jeune voudrais vraiment ce qu'ils
voudraient se faire dire en cours à
lille où vous devrez explorer dans
quelque chose de ludique sympathique
facile d'approché qui lui montrent
différents domaines sans l'obliger à en
choisir en fait que c'est vraiment parce
qu'on est allé puis on se dit que ça
serait utile autant pour les seconds
erreur à 5 qu'on a fait un document qui
peuvent vraiment qu'il faut vraiment
d'âge et puis que différents types
d'informations des longueurs de textes
des niveaux qui sont interpellants pour
différents types d'étudiants aussi donc
je pense que c'est mon 20 ans
d'enseignement qui est vraiment moduler
ce projet là pour qu'ils soient qui a
une approche vraiment pédagogique
ludique intéressante
le voilà la ligue 2 je rappelle donc
vous êtes
2 septembre édition et que vous lancez
opération 2021 qui va connaître à coup
sûr un plein succès dans tous les cas
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
nous parler au revoir au revoir en
soirée